l'île de ré situé en face de la rochelle
accueille plus de 125 mille touristes
chaque été mais saviez vous que dans les
années 60 c'était une destination plutôt
paisible sauvage secrète mais ça c'était
avant le pont lille était préservée et
elle se mérite et c'est vers l'île de ré
l'une des plus curieuses du littoral
atlantique que nous entraîne ce bac dans
lequel vous aurez pris place à la
pallice il fallait parfois attendre
jusqu'à cinq heures avant de monter sur
le bac
et puis supporter une traversée qui
pouvaient durer plus d'une heure malgré
tout de plus en plus de touristes se
rendent à l'île de ré alors dans les
années 70 le projet d'un pont reliant
l'île au continent est élaboré un pont
qui rendrait la vie plus simple aux
insulaires mais qui permettrait aussi à
plus de touristes de venir goûter à la
douceur de lille une invasion que
redouté certains étaient les
embouteillages est là qu il faut bien le
dire car ultra fera que les gens qui
venaient pour goûter le plaisir d'une
ils en ressortiront plutôt dégoûté
malgré les opposants et les recours en
justice le destin de l'île va bel et
bien basculer au mois de mai 1988 l'île
de ré n'est plus en réalité qu'une
presqu'île un pont monumentale de 2009
126 mètres relie désormais l'île au
continent
les touristes arrivent alors en masse et
construit des résidences secondaires à
tour de bras
nombreux lotissements sortent de terre
au fil des mois les promoteurs ne
respectent pas toujours le style volets
verts et huile rose caractéristiques de
ré la blanche en 1997 face à cette folie
immobilière
les maires des dix communes de l'île
pose des limites strictes
si l'obtention de permis de construire
est déjà très réglementée
les problèmes de sur urbanisation se
pose quand même alors les maires de
l'île souhaiterait réduire le nombre de
nouvelles habitations hausse de
l'immobilier invasion de touristes l'été
certains rété dit stop
et quant au début des années 2000 la
gratuité du pont est envisagée il y à
une levée de boucliers pour surtout pas
que le pont soit gratuit on est bien
conscient
c'est une démarche assez discriminatoire
de faire payer le pont cher pour éviter
d'avoir du monde mais je sais pas ce
qu'on peut trouver d'autres
le pont est resté payant 16 euros la
traversée en pleine saison depuis 2012
les recettes du péage servent à financer
des projets environnementaux pour
préserver l'île en 2010 est près de 3,5
millions de voitures ont emprunté ce
fameux pont
c'est